bonsoir un nouveau débat sur tv fil 78
dans le cadre des départementales à 2015
d'une heure consacrée en ce jeudi à 5
mars au canton de maurepas à canton qui
couvrent a également les communes de
coignières chevreuse magny les hameaux
voisins le bretonneux au total seize
communes 16 communes pour le moins être
différente autour de cette table
yves vandewalle ump candidat de l'union
de la droite conseiller sortant ismaël
havane candidat socialiste également
candidat sortant parce que vous l'avez
compris ce canton de maurepas a été
complètement redécouper isabelle refait
candidate front national et brigitte
boucher europe ecologie les verts une
candidature appuyé par le front de
gauche bonsoir à tous les quatre je
précise que vous représentez aussi un
binôme puisque vous le savez ce sont
deux candidats qui se présentent
ensemble en cas de victoire ils vont
siéger tous les deux au sein de
l'assemblée départementale
les temps de parole sont chronométrées
je vous communiquerai régulièrement elle
les indications vous pouvez échanger
entre vous la seule consigne c'est bien
évidemment de rester audible pour nos
téléspectateurs un dernier mot tout de
même avant de vous passer la parole il
ya aussi une cinquième liste sur ce
canton ne mord pas elle est portée par
sophie broue michel chapa une liste
divers droite qui n'a pas souhaité
participer à cette émission premier tour
de table et j'aimerais avoir votre
sentiment sur ce scrutin départemental
sur plusieurs points tout d'abord l'idée
du binôme hommes femmes
ça peut paraître une bonne chose pour la
parité peut-être un petit peu moins pour
la simplification administrative en tout
cas pour le nombre d'élus puisqu'il y en
aura maintenant plus 41 qui vont siéger
au sein de ce conseil départemental a
commencé avec vous ils vendent val c'est
une bonne chose cette mise en place deux
binômes il y aura plus d vu que par le
passé alors quand on parle de faire des
économies
oui je partage exactement le même
sentiment je pense que on avait voté une
réforme qui était celle du conseil
territorial qui aurait permis de
simplifier réellement le système puisque
le même conseiller aurait siégé à la
fois à la région et au département donc
c'était une vraie simplification et ça
permettait de réduire effectivement le
nombre d'élus là on passe de 39 à 42
c'est pas vraiment ça ne va pas dans le
bon sens en même temps je ne suis pas de
ceux qui disent qu'il ne fallait rien
faire
il y avait un ajustement des cantons qui
était nécessaire il y avait des
disparités trop grande
le canton l'ancien canton de chevreuse
représentait largement plus du double du
canton de viroflay par exemple est donc
un moment il faut tout de même que
chaque conseiller général représente une
part de populations à peu près
comparable alors la parité je trouve que
ça va dans le bon sens encore faut-il
bien le faire et la veine mais avant ça
n'est pas le cas il y avait une méthode
très simple qui aurait consisté à dire à
chaque partie de présente exactement le
même nombre de candidats hommes et
femmes dans tout le département est
statistiquement on serait probablement
arriver un bon résultat on a institué
des binômes obligatoire je trouve que
c'est un système à la craie compliqué
c'est moche et la tête
les hypers pour répondre à un accord
parce que dans ce cas là en général les
parties présentes des hommes là aussi
prenable et des femmes là où ça l'est
pas donc ça on le voit à chaque fois
donc c'est pas l'annoncer pas d'accord
fonctionnaire en question cette mise en
place sur sa très fort mais je pense que
c'est une mise en place test pour les
prochaines élections à d'autres niveaux
faire des binômes à tous les niveaux de
direction nous a élevés on a des binômes
à tous les niveaux de nos partis donc
pour moi ça me paraît naturel et ça
permet dans la mesure où il n'y a pas
tellement de femmes qui se déclarent
aller vomi à l'immobiliser beaucoup plus
par rapport à la politique et à amener
aussi des jeunes parce que les justement
plus de jeunes dans cette recherche de
binômes ya je pense que le profil d'âge
des candidats est beaucoup plus large
que généralement tout à fait que la
parité c'est essentiel ça fait partie de
notre époque
aujourd'hui je crois que c'est important
comme vous disiez ça va rapprocher des
femmes des jeunes
pour moi c'est le premier sens le sens
de la réforme en tout cas sur ce premier
point semble plutôt satisfait oui toutes
les deux également mais moi je pense que
ça va dans le bon sens puisque la
réalité très cruel le conseil général
aujourd'hui c'est à peine cinq femmes
sur 39 conseillers généraux donc pour on
peut dire qu'il ya quasiment pas de
femme est pire encore
au niveau des vice présidences onze
vice-présidents 0 femmes
donc la réalité est très très cruel et
je pense que justement il faut imposer
ce genre de binômes pour que ce soit que
ce soit fait parce que de deux même les
partis politiques n'ont pas tendance à
faire de la place aux femmes j'allais
dire c'est votre foi on sent le vent
partis politiques mais c'est une c'est
une réforme entre le binôme qui a été
porté par la gauche
donc lorsque vous dites c'est la faute
des partis politiques pour le coup vous
vous trompez complètement parce que
contre vents et marées j'allais dire par
de l'encens des classes politiques et
artistiques dans l'état a fait cette
réforme dans la volonté d'avoir une
parité est aujourd'hui le conseil
général qui ne respectent pas cette
règle de parité de lui même le
respectera par la loi et je pense que
c'est une bonne chose et vous me
permettez quand même de rajouter une
chose se vendent mal parlé du conseiller
territorial
moi je pense que c'est je pense toujours
que ce n'était pas une bonne idée pour
une simple raison c'est qu'on va t on
aller une professionnalisation de la
politique
et moi je pense que la politique a
besoin d'hommes et de femmes qui
viennent aussi de la société civile
comme moi qui travaille moi je suis
ingénieur et je suis élu et un
conseiller territorial ne peut pas avoir
d'activité professionnelle à côte à côte
et et avoir des hommes politiques ancrés
dans le territoire ancré dans la vraie
vie qui travaillent c'est un plus pour
la vie politique et je pense c'est ce à
quoi les français et les habitants de ce
canton aspirent au delà de cette
question de la parité il semble tout de
même que tout soit fait pour ne pas
inciter les citoyens à aller voter la
plupart des cantons été redécoupée
quelquefois on assiste à des choses
assez surprenante a sûrement pas les
ombres sont assez peu homogène puisque
je rappelle que vous êtes tous les deux
conseillers
la départementale enfin anciennement
conseiller général sortant cette
question le secteur de cheuvreux sur le
secteur de maurepas les deux jaunes ont
été redécoupée et puis surtout
actuellement est en discussion cette
réforme complète pour définir les
compétences même des conseils
départementaux qui va faire quoi entre
les départements entre les régions
finalement les électeurs vont voter sans
savoir à quoi cela va véritablement
servir ils savaient leur fait pour le
front national je vous passez à tout
d'abord la parole parce que vous êtes le
plus en plus en retard sur les temps de
parole allez-y donc sur 7 sur cette
question de voter pour l'instant alors
que les compétences ne sont pas définies
c'est assez surprenant c'est difficile
de faire campagne dans ces conditions
c'est clair que ça va pas être évident
mais toute façon nous front national il
ya une réelle dynamique pour marc saisir
un petit peu tout ce qui se passe parce
que
ben le but de l'opposition en fait c'est
de faire disparaître le département donc
du coup nous nous notre projet c'est de
dire mais tout tout tout à plat quoi
serait intéressant d'avoir vous regarde
puisque les compétences sont
actuellement discutés sur ce que vous
attendez de ce mandat tout simplement
quelles sont les compétences qui vous
semblent les plus légitimes pour un
conseil départemental celles qui sont
définies actuellement celle du social
est ce qu'il faut rester là dessus c'est
le haut niveau de l'éducation je pense
au collège puisque actuellement sur les
collèges jean qui était dépendant des
conseils départementaux
est ce que tout ça doit évoluer on
viendra on viendra vous voir tout à
l'heure brigitte boucher sur la question
des compétences et puis sur la question
aussi le disait du vote aujourd'hui sans
savoir grimper ritable mans pourquoi oui
déjà ya une loi notre les gens ça
réussit ou plus leur part les nôtres y
penseront à lenôtre et certainement pas
la réforme territoriale est en train de
se faire parce qu'elle se fait sans
diffusion dans les médias deux
principaux du fait qu'elle se faire les
gens sont pas au courant de ce à quoi on
va les les manger j'avais dépensé sais
j'exagère
donc oui il ya une réforme territoriale
est ce que c'est le département qui doit
subsister est ce qu'on doit garder les
départements est ce qu'on doit
développer les intercoms les régions et
cetera je pense qu'il faut en discuter
et et pour en discuter proprement il
faudrait faire rappelle justement la
population la mettre au courant et
définir avec la population ce qu'elle
quelle est la bonne distance quelle est
la bonne échelle les départements ils
ont été établis à l'époque pour être
accessible en une journée à cheval bon
on n'est plus à l'époque du cheval on va
un petit peu plus vite dans se déplace
on n'a pas les mêmes modes de transport
on n'a pas non plus les mêmes modes de
connexion dans l'informatique etc
donc je pense que c'est à redéfinir ça
peut être redéfinie et on n'est pas
obligé de rester sur les frontières dans
établi il ya deux siècles mais par
contre il faut les définir avec une
proximité aux citoyens
or si on va vers des intercoms très
grande si on va vers des régions de plus
en plus grande qui sont désirés par
l'europe mais qui ne sont pas
celle que la population aurait demandé
je pense qu'on va à l'encontre de ce qui
est bon pour la population et donc on
perd la démocratie la semaine
démocratique l'aspect citoyenneté qui
pour nous est essentiel sur nantes nice
c'est la base c'est la citoyenneté
donc on a vraiment on va à l'encontre de
ce qui est bon pour la population
actuellement donc donc l'échelle canton
sud où intercos à peu près la même
échelle c'est pas la même heure
justement est-ce que c'est pas le même
découpage mais c'est à peu près la seule
et j'ai alors c'est aussi la fin du mois
c'est une bonne échelle de
l'intercommunalité
après faut bien les départements et par
ballon d'essai nécessaire au final mais
après ça permet de connecter les
intercoms entre elles donc c'est pas non
moi ça me paraît une bonne échelle aussi
et et les compétences du département
l'aspect social je sais pas s'il doit
être uniquement traités au niveau du
département
il faut que ce soit traitée localement
il faut que les bureaux soient très
profondes les gens pour tout ce qui est
social mais je pense qu'un département
doit aussi devrait être autonome en ce
qui concerne je suis pour l'autonomie
alimentaire donc il y est en tout point
à la fois les zones de production
d'habitations et de production agricole
pour nourrir et en et en termes
d'énergie donc aussi pour qu'en cas de
problème on soit ou non reste
indépendant cas de problèmes politiques
terrorisme ce que vous voulez en gare on
garde une indépendance si on garde un
mode à une vie qui qu'ils soient
soutenables donc vous fait réagir y ait
beaucoup de choses sur les propositions
sur les compétences et tout ça mais sur
les champs aussi la nécessité de cette
chambre départementale
il est important quand on voit les
intercours de cette façon je tirais le
depuis depuis deux ans on est engagé
dans une véritable révolution des
structures du pays
parfois un peu anarchique d'ailleurs
parce que il ya six mois on nous
annoncer la fin des départements
on voit très bien maintenant qu'après
avoir créé de très grandes régions
provinces on ne pourra pas vraiment
abandonné l'échelon départemental
mais en tout état cause l'île de france
quand même est un cas un peu à part est
différent et je pense que en
ile-de-france effectivement on a besoin
d'un échelon qui permettent de garder
une proximité avec la population et
c'est vrai que le département joue de ce
point de vue un rôle qui est tout à fait
privilégiée c'est un acteur majeur de la
vie quotidienne de chacun d'entre nous
parce qu'il est tôt auprès des communes
lorsqu'on va s'adresser au centre
communal d'action sociale de sa commune
en réalité le véritable acteur derrière
c'est le conseil général parce que c'est
lui qui en matière de handicap en
matière de personnes âgées en matière de
jeunesse en matière de chômeurs c'est le
conseil général qui est à la manoeuvre
derrière même si effectivement le
guichet ce sera peut-être le centre
communal d'action sociale il faut pas
transférer ses compétences vers les
intercommunalités qui vont d'ailleurs
s'agrandir alors soyons aujourd'hui les
intercommunalités sont absolument pas
capable de prendre la relève du conseil
général il faudrait d'abord qu'elles
soient stabilisés ce qui est loin d'être
le cas
il faudra ensuite qu'elle ait acquis un
minimum de maturité
peut-être que saint quentin en yvelines
a acquis une certaine maturité
on en est très loin dans la plupart des
intercommunalités qui sont très récentes
et par conséquent elles sont incapables
de prendre la relève
et puis surtout ça suppose quand même
d'avoir je dirais une certaine assise
territoriale une certaine surface pour
réellement mutualiser la dépense sociale
sur un territoire suffisamment vaste
question des compétences et de l'échelon
sur la question de l'échelon du
département
ce qu'il faut de pas il faut que le
département existe ou n'existe pas moi
je veux être en cohérence je suis
conseiller général sortant
je suis candidat je vais pas vous dire
que je suis pour la suppression du
département ce serait illogique
je connais par contre des conseillers
généraux
qui sont contre le souhaitent la
suppression du département etc ont
décidé de pas être candidat au moins une
certaine cohérence
moi je pense que les départements a
toute sa raison d'être ne serait-ce que
sur l'aspect social
ils vendent val la dila dit tout à
l'heure effectivement le conseil général
a une compétence première qui est celle
du de l'action sociale et je crois que
la meilleure façon de garantir une
action sociale qui est commune à
l'ensemble des yvelinois c'est d'avoir
un organisme qui puisse mutualiser tout
ça en une seule entité
parce que demain je pense que 60 les
clés les intercoms n'ont pas la capacité
aujourd'hui de faire de l'action sociale
mad mais tombe demain elles puissent le
faire
rien ne garantit que sur l'ensemble du
département tel qu'il existerait vous
auriez une égalité de traitement en
termes d'action sociale sur tout le
territoire et l'action sociale c'est
comme aider les plus démunis les
handicapés et il faut absolument qu'il y
ait un organisme qui centralise tout ça
et qu'ils garantissent un même service à
tous cela me semble extrêmement
important
ça va réagir on passe la parole mais
très rapidement parce que je reviens à
vous parce qu'elle souhaitait un détail
si on remplace les cantons vd par tout
le monde par les intercoms il faut que
le mode de vote d'élection des
représentants des vainqueurs quo soit
aussi démocratique que ça peut l'être
pour le département ce qui n'est pas le
cas aujourd'hui
après vous souhaitiez continuer je
souhaitais juste parler des refonder des
cantons qui ont été faits qui ont été
faits effectivement le canton de
maurepas a été redessiné complètement
moi j'ai été je le suis toujours pour
la refonte des de ces cantons et je vous
l'expliqué rapidement c'est qu'il y
avait des aberrations
vous aviez des cantons villes par
exemple trappe était un canton ville je
crois que xavi il me ressemble à du
reflet est un canton ville alors il
reflet ses trente mille 30 mille
habitants c'était 35000 habitants à
côté vous aviez deux grands de grands
cantons à plus de 50000 habitants ce
qu'elle est aujourd'hui les cohérente et
quand c'était ce qui était mon cas le
vôtre c'est ma femme
ce qui veut dire qu'en termes de
représentativité vous aviez des
conseillers généraux qui représentait
plus que d'autres mais qui avait qu'une
seule voie
donc c'est tout sauf démocratique donc
aujourd'hui ce sera jamais parfait on
n'arrivera jamais à une représentation
ultime mais en tout cas c'est un premier
pas qui a été fait pour cette réforme
et qu'en ce sens elle est correcte
rajouter à la parité du binôme ça la
rend je pense très bonne réforme des
compétences voici quelles sont les
compétences qui vous semblent
nécessaires est-ce que cet échelon
départemental aussi est nécessaire ou
pas aujourd'hui
ben moi je crois qu'il faut garder le
rôle de la commune et du département et
ça c'est important parce que il faut la
proximité pour les touts les français on
est aussi aux le but je pense d'ici 2020
du du nouveau du nouveau plan en fait
ces intercommunalités hyper région et
europe parce qu'il faut pas se leurrer
tout va vers l'europe quand même si on
en arrive là c'est parce qu'il ya des
directives européennes derrière et on
veut faire en fait de nos départements
plutôt des états unis pour que ce
deviennent des états unis européen et ça
nous nous sommes contre tout ça il faut
garder les rôles des communes des
régions et de l'état
ca c
les départements et ça c'est primordial
on va perdre sinon tout notre ruralité
également tous nos artisans parce que
voilà c'est ça fait partie aussi tout ça
du département est vraiment je suis plus
dans cette directive là quelles sont vos
attentes auprès des conseillers
départementaux les conseillers généraux
nous sommes allez vous poser la question
voici vos réponses et on se retrouve
ensuite pour la suite de ce débat
dany rénovation qui fasse attention à
tout ce que tout ce qui se passe qu'il
construise pas n'importe quoi ça coûte
cher d'ailleurs je pense que pour les
trafics routier et puis les rer les
choses comme ça faire des améliorations
plus tôt plus vous lutter contre la
fraude qui est un petit peu plus mon je
dis pas qu'il faut pas aider les
personnes qui ont des difficultés mais
bien ciblé quand même hein parce que moi
je vois autour de moi qu'il ya des
personnes qui ne travaillent pas qui
attendent un petit peu trouvent sur
soul et à quoi il faudrait qu'il ya
peut-être plus de synergie avec la avec
les conseillers régionaux par rapport
des politiques responsables j'aimerais
bien que
qu'il y ait des buts j'ai voté qui soit
un peu plus conséquent malgré la crise
actuellement pour essayer pour l'aide à
la personne
on va regarder à présent les
chronomètres qui vont s'afficher les
temps de parole pour faire un point ils
vendent mal de 1058 ismail havane peu
près 4 minutes et brigitte boucher sur
trois minutes 42 et puis vous avez un
peu plus de retard un peu moins de deux
minutes sur le temps de parole peut-être
tout de même un mot à présent on va
s'attarder tout à l'heure sur
quelques-unes des compétences qui
jusqu'à présent en tout cas été les
compétences et ça devrait rester sauf
surprise sur conseil départemental et ça
vous donnera l'occasion de développer
des points de programme pour les
électeurs mais ses électeurs en tout cas
il sera difficile de les déplacer aux
yeux on parle d'une forte abstention
encore j'aimerais savoir comment vous
faites campagne et quel message vous
passé auprès des électeurs pour qu'ils
se déplacent et qu'ils aillent voter
tout simplement
qu'est ce que vous leur dites
aujourd'hui moi je leur dis que si une
obsessionnelle juste au niveau national
on entend aussi assez peu parler des
programmes en fait que ce soit du côté
de l'ump on parle du fn ps maintenant
pour contrer le front national qui
apparaît en tête
on a du mal à entendre parler avec la
position tout ça est quand même un peu
les cuves des choses c'est vrai que
la france traverse une crise qui est une
crise économique et sociale et qui se
doublent progressivement d'une crise
politique qui s'aggrave qui n'est pas
absolument nouvelle mais qui s'aggrave
quand même au fil des années et donc
c'est effectivement préoccupant pour
tous les élus que nous sommes parce que
nous sommes là dans une démocratie pour
représenter la population et si la
population ne se reconnaît pas dans ses
élus ses dessins c'est quand même un
vrai souci sur la question de la
légitimité c'est le nombre d'électeurs
aussi qu'ils se déplacent ça peut poser
un problème pour les questions bien
entendu la légitimité des élus elle est
fondé d'abord sur une participation
élevée et le message que je fais passer
c'est que de toute façon il est du
devoir des citoyens de voter peu importe
qu'ils votent selon son sentiment mais
qu'ils votent
ça me paraît essentiel et deuxièmement
on peut se désintéresser de la politique
peut-être le problème c'est que la
politique s'intéresse à vous tous les
jours et que par conséquent c'est un
devoir de citoyen dans une république on
a la chance en france de pouvoir voter
alors on n'est peut-être pas toujours
content du résultat mais c'est quand une
bonne raison d'aller voter sur la
question de l'abstention
on dit souvent que l'abstention ça
favorise le front national donc vous
n'appelez pas les électeurs à aller
voter
non parce que nous on est encore je vais
me reprendre en fait le résultat des
anciennes élections comme le les
élections européennes les élections
municipales dernièrement qui vous c'est
vrai le front national a eu un réel
succès on est toujours dans cette
dynamique
donc nous espérons plus de 30% je pense
en notre faveur sur ces élections là je
pense qu'il y aura de l'abstention mais
peut-être pas tant qu'on le dit les gens
sont assez sont quand même dans une
réalité se rendent compte qu'on est en
train de les d épuiser financièrement
que tout se dégrade l'action sociale se
dégrade les handicapés les chômeurs et
je vous dis on va toujours vers ce sens
europe europe europe et ça c'est ça il
faut se l'interdire c'est on n'a pas
besoin de ça la france n'a pas besoin de
ça et
donc moi je pense que l'abstention nom
vous dit ça joue en faveur du front
national est désormais là réellement
changé je pense que les choses vont
vraiment bougé et ces élections là vont
être aussi primordial pour les futures
élections régionales et nationales parce
que mon front national véritablement cet
angle nous c'est matin ça va mais enfin
ça c'est sûr que là ça va être le bon
thermomètre pour li na pour les autres
les régionales et pour les nationales et
pour ensuite voir pour effectivement
régional et puis 2010 est ensuite ce
sera législatif présidentialisme et la
vanne sur l'abstention sur la sanction
va vous me permettez de dire que tout ce
que je viens d'entendre ça me permet
modestement de dire qu'il faut replacer
le débat de là où il doit être
il s'agit d'une élection locale avant
tout eelv et conseiller général
moi je suis conseiller général on n'est
pas du même bord peu importe mais on a
chacun à un moment ou à un autre
travailler sur des dossiers qui sont
locaux moi ma permanence jette des gens
qui habitent à côté de chez moi
jette pas des gens qui habitent dans le
département d'à côté ce sont mes voisins
lorsque j'ai des associations c'est des
associations de chez moi du canton donc
l'élection il est avant tout local pour
aider un canton
et c'est le rôle du conseiller général
il faut replacer l'élection dans ce
contexte
donc effectivement c'est extrêmement
difficile on passe le cas chez moi j'ai
un discours de vérité
c'est sûr qu'aujourd'hui les
responsables et gens sont assez déçus de
la politique mais nous on a su bien
pourquoi socialiste a cité mais lorsque
vous allez en local aussi elle trouvera
une valise sûr que moi je suis sortant
et je suis candidat par rapport au bilan
que j'ai fait que je considère comme bon
et que je souhaite défendre et lorsqu on
recentre cette élection à l'échelle
locale on se rend compte que les élus de
gauche surtout dans le département des
yvelines ont eu des actions extrêmement
forte et j'espère qu'on pourra en parler
sur le développement économique
on attend la croyance est pour quelque
chose sur le volet social
on a pu réorienter beaucoup de choses et
ça ça sert qui ça sert les habitants de
de chaque canton et des yvelines donc je
dis aux habitants du canton ne mord pas
d'aller voter parce que c'est une
politique de proximité au plus proche
ce dont il s'agit c'est de voter pour
des hommes et des femmes qui sont en
capacité de les rencontrer tous les
jours directement people une proximité
de la proximité
je vous passe également la parole sur
cette question de l'abstention est ce
que ça vous inquiète et puis je peux
vous y 4 ajouter une petite question
c'est la question de la division aussi à
gauche parce que là vous êtes côte à
côte mais sur les programmes et sur les
cons d'affinités ça s'arrête là
aujourd'hui la gauche a du mal à se
mettre d'accord et à la gauche y est à
la gauche qui se nomme libéral et ya la
gauche qui se nomme pas libéral
le libéralisme pour moi est contraire à
la gauche donc c'est tout mais non
l'abstention nous on jette la sonnette
d'alarmé si les gens ne vont plus voter
c'est parce qu'ils pensent en
particulier que la politique elle elle
est la même et par exemple à la réforme
territoriale elle a commencé à se faire
avant le gouvernement actuel on en
parlait avant déjà donc c'est pas si
elle compte
oui mais il ya quand même une certaine
continuité dans la politique et je
dirais plus dans l'absence de politique
parce que les choix faits que ce soit
par macro ou précédemment ils sont faits
en faveur des grandes multinationales
des on en train de préparer à un grand
marché transatlantique qui risque de
vraiment mettre mal tout le pouvoir
politique et même la notion même d'état
la notion de pouvoir régional d'eco au
niveau des communes etc et est donc on
va perdre le pouvoir en fait le citoyen
va perdre le pouvoir les droits de
l'homme auront plus de sens quelque part
et l'est et la république a plus
vraiment de sens si ça passe et là on
est très mal et nous on pense qu'il faut
vraiment que les populations se met en
branle de dire à un peu comme cyril à ce
ce maître se prennent près de la
question politique c'est resserre la
gestion de la vie de la gestion de la
cité en main et avec les gens qui sont
plus professionnels de la chose par les
élus ensemble avec les que les élus
s'appuient sur les associations de
zurich occupe des gens des citoyens et
ses appuis beaucoup plus aussi l'or lors
décision là sur les gens pour que
justement il y est pas cette manière
cette peur du politique château et pour
pour faire barrage à à cette puissance
ultralibérale qui est en train de tout
casser en fait on est on est en train on
est on est dans un schéma très à mon
avis assez grave par rapport
au fait de garder un pouvoir politique
et c'est notre notre signal c'est ça
c'est prenez prenez votre destin en main
prenez la gestion de la cité en main
allant vers une démocratie participative
une sixième république
voilà allons allons allons leur faire et
à dire mais alors tant que seconde parce
que vous êtes en avance et non vrai plus
il n'aurait plus de temps après par la
suite sans que les mêmes choses que je
partage sur ce qu'elle a dit sauf que je
suis obligé de réagir c'est juste pas
vous en 30 secondes à lévis mais quand
on mord pas je me suis battu pour la
sauvegarde des cinémas de proximité
contre des grandes entreprises multiples
accès etc
moi moi moi en tant que conseiller
général j'ai défendu des associations
qui travaillent dans l'action sociale
parce qu'elle n'avait pas de subventions
et leur disait on ferme les robinets
parce qu'il ya passé d'argent donc il ya
un moment faut pas prendre cette
élection comme un auditoire pour
balancer beaucoup de choses nationale
aussi juste soit elle est en retard et
c'est en ce sens que sortant vous
devriez être content de moi d'accord
c'est un peu tard maintenant mais bon
pour la suite
la politique c'est un vin c'est un très
bon mot mais effectivement la réalité de
cette élection est elle est quotidienne
pour les gens ils se lèvent le matin ils
vont commencer par emprunter des routes
la plupart des routes qu'ils vont
emprunter sont faites par le conseil
général et elles sont plutôt en bon état
que je sache ils vont conduire leurs
enfants au collège c'est à nouveau le
conseil général
peut-être qu'un enfant plus petits vont
l'amener à l'école primaire elle aura
peut-être été elle pas obligatoirement
mais peut-être été financée en partie
par le conseil général
ensuite ils vont aller travailler
peut-être qu'ils travailleront dans une
entreprise qui aura été aidé par le
conseil général à se développer
et peut-être que le soir ils iront voir
un parent qui sera en maison de retraite
et qui bénéficiera d'une aide du conseil
général c'est ça la réalité quotidienne
du conseil général ou poursuit ce débat
sur tv fils est consacrée aux cantons ne
mord pas débat qui vous concerne
directement si vous êtes résident d'une
quinzaine de communes de magny les
hameaux à maurepas en passant par
coignières voisins-le-bretonneux
chevreuse on le disait tout à l'heure
les compétences pour demain elle des
conseils départementaux ne sont pas
encore connues elles se discute par les
parlementaires il faudra pourtant aller
voter les 22 et 29 mars
on peut tout de même imaginer que
certaines prérogatives ne vont pas
beaucoup changé on va s'attarder dessus
quelques instants pour évoquer quelques
unes de vos propositions sur la question
de la solidarité justement personnes en
difficultés pour se loger situation de
handicap et puis la question du
vieillissement de la population sont des
thèmes qui qui préoccupe et qui
concernent directement les conseillers
départementaux il vante valve vous êtes
puisque vous sept sortants de la
majorité on ressemble à de l'assemblée
départementale vous êtes satisfait de la
politique qui a été menée terme de
solidarité au sens large
quelles seraient les axes encore à
renforcer aujourd'hui cultes et je crois
qu'on peut être fier du bilan
d'ailleurs tout récemment encore on
disait que le conseil général des
yvelines était l'un des mieux gérées de
france c'était sur une antenne
concurrentes comme on dit pas vraiment
locale le social paris et c'est le
domaine d'action numéro un du conseil
général c'est plus de 60% du budget qui
est consacrée à l'aide sociale
souvent d'ailleurs sous fait sous forme
d' aide personnelle
si c'est une allocation personnalisée
d'autonomie pour les personnes âgées
ça peut être des aides pour les
handicapés ou évidemment tout le monde
le connaît le rsa le conseil général est
donc un acteur majeur cela dit nous
avons besoin d'aller plus loin
on constate notamment qu'on a beaucoup
de problèmes avec l'assertion en réalité
l'insertion ne fonctionne pas bien
certes on est dans un contexte
économique qui me fascine certainement
pas la réinsertion des chômeurs c'est
que l'actionnaire un marché de l'emploi
dynamique ça se passerait mieux
néanmoins c'est quand même une vraie
difficulté pour des phénomènes très
connu d'ailleurs souvent le manque de
formation même parfois même de formation
tout court à la base quand on ne sait ni
lire ni compter ce qui arrive quand même
fraction des français aujourd'hui c'est
quasiment impossible de trouver un
emploi et donc on est en train de
réfléchir à la mise en place à la fois
deux pôles de proximité de décentraliser
un petit peu notre système social pour
être plus près encore de la population
en se rapprochant notamment des
intercommunalités de telle sorte qu'on
ait une synergie entre les deux et puis
nous réfléchissons
réfléchissons aussi à la mise en place
notamment le système de formation
professionnelle pour les chômeurs certes
on est à la marge de la compétence du
conseil général mais de toute façon on a
du mal à fixer des compétences puisque
elles sont en discussion au parlement
c'est d'ailleurs un peu extravagant
c'est la première élection à laquelle je
participe sans savoir exactement ce que
nous aurons à faire
bon je pousse un petit peu dans les
grandes lignes ont fait parler la mesure
où dans les brouillons csdl solidarité
on se sera pas bouleversée donc on va
garder la solidarité il ya le domaine
des transports qui était évoqué tout à
l'heure je j'ai parlé des routes
mais le conseil général et à côté du
stif du syndicat d'île de france un
acteur majeur dans le domaine des
transports on est inauguré tout
récemment le tramway t6 à vélizy on a la
tangentielle ou est ce qui va permettre
de relier notre secteur au nord du
département
donc on reste un acteur majeur dans
beaucoup de domaines je vais pas
m'étendre ici on va afficher dans un
instant les chronomètres juste qu'ils
avaient leur fait pour le front national
je vous passe donc la parole à présent
sur cette question du social sur les
dernières communications faites par
marine le pen au niveau national une
politique en faveur des anciens être
face à la dépendance domotique aussi
pour les personnes âgées à domicile sont
quelques points du programme qui sont
communs avec tous les candidats du front
national à travers la france
oui parce que je rejoins monsieur hand
quand il dit que le département du 78
c'est vrai que c'est un des plus mauvais
département au plan national mais il ya
aussi encore des beaucoup de lacunes
le front national ce qui veut faire
c'est qu'on par le biais justement de
faire entrer des élus dans le conseil
c'est de pouvoir un petit peu contrôler
tout ce qui s'y passe parce que
malheureusement il y encore des abus et
encore des fraudes et des choses qui ne
sont pas assez claires donc nous que
notre souhait c'est bien de vérifier si
tout ça est bien organisé derrière et
bien fait par contre nous nos priorités
c'est vrai que ça sera déjà des
prestations destinées aux personnes
âgées handicapées ça c'est un axe fort
du front national développer et donner
un soutien par le biais de maison
départementale pour les personnes
handicapées ensuite c'est vrai qu'il y
avait aussi le
au niveau de l'action sociale pareil une
solidarité envers les personnes âgées
ont contrôlant un petit peu plus le
revenu le fameux rsa et il ya énormément
de fraude et donc travailler directement
avec justement les caisses d'allocations
familiales parce que ce il se rend
compte c'est sûr qu'il ya des fraudes et
des mutuelles
les mutualités également alors ça il va
falloir lutter fortement contre ces abus
et ainsi avec ses touts ses bas ses
économies pouvoir aider les personnes
âgées
sur ce plan là est bon mais je rejoins
aussi également les transports monsieur
pour les transports et donc il ya
quelque chose quand même à faire là
dessus aussi
oui j'ai bouché vous porter la
candidature d'europe écologie les verts
mais également celles du front de gauche
à travers votre binôme notre action peut
être sur le social aussi sur la question
des fraudes par exemple déjà si tous les
gens qui ont droit au rsa le demandait
le conseil général aurait du mal à le
payer parce qu'un à plat qui font pas la
demande
c'est vraiment un problème de
financement du rsa pour ceux qui ont
droit déjà mais c'est un problème de
budget global nous on a remarqué aussi
que les par exemple les maisons de
retraite sont très très cher dans les
yvelines et sont plus chers que dans la
plupart des autres départements d'île de
france et il n'y a pas de maison de
retraite par exemple départementale pour
les personnes les plus démunies
on pourrait créer ce genre de fin d'
espaces
ça me paraît important dans la
redistribution le handicap il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de choses à faire et
quand on parle de handicap les gens
parlent pense toujours aux gens qui sont
contre problème un marché mais handicap
c'est beaucoup plus que ça il ya des
gens qui voient pas et jean-pierre donc
pas etc et en sait très peu traité puis
à tous les enfants qui ont des problèmes
dès le départ et qui a passé à l'âge
adulte sont assez peu assisté rien pour
les adultes handicapées de naissance du
ray entre mantes aux autres donc c'est
je pense qu abu il ya beaucoup beaucoup
la france a beaucoup en général a
beaucoup beaucoup de choses à faire sur
le handicap
sinon il ya aussi la formation
les jeunes il ya des gens qui sont pour
mettre des caméras pour ramper pour eux
je dirais observer les agressions c'est
pas ça qu'il faut faire faut accompagner
les jeunes dès le départ des systèmes
comme passerelles sont pas suffisamment
financée par exemple il faudrait
généraliser ça c'est dans l'assistance
des jeunes repérés dès les écoles les
collèges pour éviter qu'ils tombent dans
dans une délinquance
c'est cet été c'est un des points du
programme du front national parce que
vous ne regardez pas votre nom mais
c'est assez énorme point social en fait
c'est important c'est important social
c'est l'assistance pour empêcher que les
jeunes en fin d'hiver je veux dire
d'accord est là et là il ya vraiment il
ya vraiment un travail à faire donc je
pense qu'on met pas les moyens
suffisants pour le faire dans la mesure
où la situation sociale se dégrade pour
un certain nombre de gens sont des cas
qui augmente
au nom donc il ya donc il faut mettre
plus l'état n'est pas là pour donner des
emplois ces entreprises qui donnent
d'emplois mais par contre il y doit
aider ce qu'il n'y ait pas de dérive
quand quand l'emploi manque ou brun
clair il a dit qu'au delà des cohésions
sociales se passe il sur la vidéo
protection à dire parce qu'elle est
clairement question je vous fait réagir
parce que ça fait partie des produits du
programme dans les collèges par exemple
plus de vidéoprotection lutter contre
les trafics ce sont des points du
programme aussi de marine le pen et du
front national dans cette élection
et quand vous entendez c'est pas
forcément la solution vous répondez quoi
cissé c'est la première solution pour
enrayer un gros problèmes de drogue de
raquette dans les collèges et ça c'est
essentiel la vidéosurveillance dans cet
établissement
la forte délinquance a lieu entre 12 ans
et 15 ans et moi pour moi moi je crois à
l'éducation aux quelques le compte pas y
en a eu et ça arrive
ça arrive dans tous les collèges faudra
se leurrer où il y en a c'est sûr on
vient sur cette thématique du social on
va parler des collégiens prennent
d'ailleurs des compétences du collège
parce que ça fait partie des
prérogatives des en tout cas jusqu'à
présent ça devrait vous devrez pas
changé c'est toujours la même chose ça
va pas changer à rassurer nous ça
devrait rester des compétences du
conseil départemental ancien conseil
général donc sur la question du social
aujourd'hui le département vous qui
avait siégé mais dans l'opposition au
sein de ce conseil départemental
il ya encore mieux à faire que ce soit
plus homogène quelles sont les
propositions que vous portez sur ce
domaine vont nous donner les
propositions que nous on porte me
christine merci donc clivé très content
de l'action du conseil général dans me
sur le volet social nous on s'est
beaucoup battu sur le volet social parce
qu'on trouve que c'est jamais assez pour
une simple raison
et là je sais pas moi qui veux le dire
c'est je vais vous dire ce qu'a dit la
chambre régionale des comptes en 2012 en
2011 au pardon elle a pointé le conseil
général des yvelines comme étant un des
départements des cinq départements qui
donnait le mois des aides sociales par
habitant pourtant c'est un département
qui est riche donc ce qui est fait au
niveau de l'action sociale effet au
minimum donc moi je les ai déjà dit au
conseil général plusieurs fois donc
quand c'est moi qui le dit c'est moi qui
le dit mais quand c'est la chambre
régionale des comptes qui enfonce le
clou je pense que on peut pas douter sur
la diversité de ces choses et il y a un
autre gros problème c'est que nous avons
dans le passé nous avons dans le
département des yvelines et j'étais à la
commission affaires sociales
nous avons un certain nombre d'
yvelinois handicapés lourds qui doivent
aller en belgique et je me suis battu
avec plusieurs collègues pour qu'on
puisse enfin anticiper tout cela est
créé dans notre département des
structures d'accueil pour ces enfants et
ces familles afin de leur éviter ce
transport jusqu'en belgique et on est
dans un département riche qui fait les
choses un minimum je pense qu'on peut
investir pour ces enfants là pour qu'il
puisse rester dans le département donc
ça c'est une de nos propositions
on est dans un département qui est
vieillissant donc nous ce que l'on
propose c'est renforcer le service
public au grand âge parce que ça nous en
pl
semble important d'anticiper le
vieillissement de la population et le
département des yvelines dans les années
à venir sera un des départements les
plus âgés donc il est important de
prendre ça en compte et nous souhaitons
créer des maisons de retraite
médicalisées public qui puisse être
accessible à tout le monde et enfin
soutenir toutes les associations d aide
au maintien à domicile des personnes
âgées parce que c'est excessivement
important et nous avons des propositions
aussi sur la santé pour ouvrir beaucoup
plus les aides sur la santé et je
rajoute pour terminer que nous sommes
dans un contexte économique extrêmement
difficile
beaucoup de gens sont en difficulté les
seuls le seul organisme aujourd'hui
capables de les aider c'est le
département des yvelines et il doit
prendre cela en plus prend en charge
complète au lieu quelques fois d'aller
sur des dépenses recherche et
développement qui peuvent être
justifiées mais excessive ils en valent
vous fait réagir juste après on avisera
les chronomètres pour vous dire que vous
laisse à peu près une minute comme ça
voudrait minutes actuellement le
handicap c'est le premier poste de
dépenses du conseil général c'est plus
de 180 millions d'euros par an donc
c'est un effort qui financier qui est
tout à fait considérables et donc je
pense que on est dans la bonne voie
mon collègue évoqué à l'instant
effectivement le cas des enfants
autistes mais c'est un problème qui
n'est pas illinois c'est un problème
national effectivement la prise en
charge de l'autisme en france est un
problème mais ce n'est pas une loi
quant à la chambre même au niveau local
même si c'est parce qu'on peut pas se
renvoyer la langue mais effective mais
on fait ce que font tous les
départements c'est-à-dire qu'on aime des
familles effectivement rires des enfants
en belgique parce qu'on n'a pas les
micropuces de combustion et porter un
projet pour le départ du milliard
éventements du monde ne nous agissons
dans un cadre qui est un cadre national
c'est la loi qui fixe le cadre d'actions
un peu le tour des conseils généraux
présents prêts à les dire
rappelez-nous
attends je voudrais répondre simplement
j'ai bien lu le rapport de la chambre
régionale des comptes
effectivement il dit qu on dépense moins
pour une raison très simple c'est que le
département des yvelines a la chance par
rapport à d'autres départements d'avoir
une population qui est globalement plus
favorisés on va délire et par conséquent
il y avait moins de dépenses sociales
malheureusement la situation économique
se dégrade en on devait indemniser à
l'étiage on a dû être un moment où on
indemnise est à peu près neuf mille
personnes au chômage par an on a
largement passé le cap des 20 milles et
on voit s'envoler effectivement on a les
moyens de déployer encore aimer mais on
voit s'envoler effectivement la dépense
sociale notamment au titre du rsa
oui on va afficher à présent les
chronomètres si c'est possible pour voir
vous êtes à peu près tous dans une
fourchette autour de 2,8 et et neuf
minutes
en ce qui concerne le vandalisme et la
vanne et brigitte boucher également ils
avaient leur fait vous avez un peu plus
de 2 de retard et donc sur cette
thématique à présent qui est l'éducation
on y vient je vais vous passez donc
directement la parole
sur la question de l'éducation
brièvement on a évoqué l'importance
attachée par le front national à la
question de la vidéo protection de la
lutte contre les trafics dans les
établissements scolaires quels sont les
autres propositions ou tout simplement
les propositions que vous portez sur le
la question des collèges qui reste une
compétence importante aussi la gestion
des collèges pour non pas sur les
programmes qu'on soit bien d'accord mais
sur la gestion tout même des divisions
dans l'union isabelle rey fait alors le
front national lui ce qu'ils souhaitent
c'est renforcer la vitalité justement
avec des équipements au niveau des
équipes et justement les collèges avec
donc tout ce qui accompagne le collège
en fait les cantines et puis des
bibliothèques et tout ça en fait y'a pas
que le problème de survie de
vidéosurveillance et les collèges sont
on va dire il faut les faux les animés
en fait sur la question des décollages
yves vandewalle je reviens vers vous
parce qu'il ya aussi un programme qui
est porté par le département en tout cas
c'est une des ambitions qui portait par
ces listes communes à travers le
département d'équipé aussi en tableaux
numériques moderniser un petit peu les
collèges
c'est exact oui on a d'abord il faut
bien rappeler que le conseil général
étant n'est pas en charge de la partie
enseignement la direction des
établissements les enseignants les
programmes et l'entraidé nationale eric
ma revanche ça c'est nous on fait
effectivement qui créons je dirai tout
l'ambiance de travail
donc nous le feu nous l'avons fait en
modernisant concerts et des rats blement
la la centaine de collèges publics et
privés qui se trouve dans le département
et puis effectivement on essaie
d'accompagner des pédagogies innovantes
qui sont fondées notamment sur l'usagé
du numérique
donc ce sera fait à travers un programme
important qui vise à desservir en fibre
optique les collèges parce que si on
veut travailler en ligne il faut avoir
des débits informatiques suffisantes
donc on essaie d'avancer est
effectivement en équipant aussi les
enfants de tablettes ont conduit des
expérimentations dans plusieurs collèges
en ayant donné des tablettes numériques
effectivement aux élèves
le numérique c'est une bonne piste ont
partagé ce point de vue pour l'équipe et
les collèges aujourd'hui il faut
développer les tablettes on sait qu il
ya des fois deux écoles qui s'opposent
sur cette question des tablettes
je suis effectivement d'accord sur 7 sur
cette proposition le conseil général
déjà va dans 160 en ce sens là il faut
l'amplifier
il faut le faire en concertation avec
l'équipe pédagogique même si le conseil
général s'occupe entre guillemets que
des murs on ne peut pas fournir un
matériel pédagogique 100 derrière avoir
quand même une idée pédagogique qui doit
s'inscrire avec cet outil ça me semble
important et l'autre point qui me semble
si important c'est la réhabilitation de
nos collèges
parce que les collèges ne sont pas tous
au même état dans le canton et il est
important de d'avancé sur 7
cette réhabilitation alors moi je
je suis la réhabilitation du collège de
lamarzelle à coignières qui qui étaient
abandonnées qu'on a pu leur faire
revenir c'est ça bouge tout le temps en
tout cas il faut absolument que ce soit
fait je crois aussi à magny les hameaux
il ya une réhabilitation de collège qui
tarde et c'est une demande importante
des femmes y est on est on a
l'obligation de le faire on doit avoir
quand même donner les outils à nos
enfants pour bien pour bien pour bien
travailler donc nous on veut se battre
sur la réhabilitation complète de tous
les collèges sans exception et ensuite
on souhaite aussi ce truc soutenir les
structures locales qui aide à la lutte
contre le décrochage scolaire
ça semble aussi important voilà les
propositions nous qu'on fait au niveau
de l'éducation débouché sur la question
de l'éducation la lutte contre le
décrochage scolaire c'est clair c'est
important le numérique ne remplace pas
le professeur au collège saint-nicolas
denis il est écrit l'enseignement passe
par le coeur je pense pas qu'un écran
vous vous amène sa quand quelqu'un vous
transmets une information il fait des
gestes ils vous regardent et c'est
l'écran ne le fait pas
donc ça remplace absolument pas sa passe
est un outil mais il faut uniquement le
considérer comme un outil je suis
chercheur j'ai commencé ma recherche
sans ordinateur je n'utilisais un tous
les jours maintenant tout le temps je
connais les limites de ce que de
l'utilisation de ce genre d'outil enfin
voilà et ses possibilités
donc ça remplace pas et l'éducation
c'est beaucoup les les grands les aînés
étaient autour des des plus jeunes
donc c'est beaucoup plus de personnes
autour et ça qu'on fait et ce même dans
l'assistance après je connais pas les
moyens du conseil départemental mais
c'est vrai qu'au niveau des communes on
essaye de le faire donc je pense que les
financements au niveau des départements
disons pour éviter une fracture entre
entre les différentes communes
il faut qu'il y ait une uniformisation
de ce genre de
dead de manière à ce que rattraper ceux
qui sont moins aidés dans leur milieu
familial par exemple donc ya un travail
à faire
si on veut vraiment faire les choses je
pense aussi je ne sais pas si c'est
vraiment dur sort complètement du
ressort du département
la france a basé son économie sur la
consommation c'est une erreur pour un
écologiste n'a pas de sens on doit pas
augmenter la consommation éternellement
puisque c'est c l'élévation de la
production et ses évasions d'effet de
serre etc et donc on détruit en fait
notre planète en consommant est par
contre on a détruit les moyens de
production on a détruit
on a supprimé les collèges techniques on
a su priver des lycées techniques on a
supprimé les formations techniques qui
permettent aussi de d'insérer des gens
qui sont pas des personnes intellectuels
dans dans la dans la structure et qui
permettent la création l'innovation pour
innover il faut savoir fabriquer soi
même un petit peu nom est là jusqu'à
quel point au niveau du département on
pourrait pas créer des départs des des
filières un peu techniques liées à la
richesse du département
je pense aux forêts je pensais à fin aux
ressources aux ressources énergétiques
alliée à la biomasse forêts etc et aux
bâtiments à l'architecturé couplé et c
est pour les cantines aussi présenté au
mondial
il est en forme mais là je pense que on
a vraiment un moyen de re naissance
d'une valve s'est beaucoup de choses qui
ont été dites et réponse est très simple
la formation professionnelle c'est un
enjeu majeur
je suis parfaitement d'accord avec ça
mais c'est de la compétence normalement
du conseil régional ile de france
c'est vrai cette question cellules dont
ses compétences principales et sur le
commerce les chemins avec alternat
déclare alors dans les yvelines c'est un
cas un peu particulier parce
qu'effectivement on avait on a une
chambre de commerce qui a toujours été
extrêmement active dans le domaine de la
formation professionnelle ça a été avec
la chambre de paris
probablement l'une des plus actives de
france je ne sais pas si j'espère
qu'elle en aura toujours les moyens
demain mais c'est vrai qu'elle a
énormément d'écoles y compris tout près
d'ici
pour afficher
mettre une dernière fois on aurait pu
aborder encore d'autres choses notamment
le dynamisme local parce qu'il est
important de développer l le local ça
fait ça fait partie des compétences
excusez moi donc vous êtes fait partie
des compétences jusqu'à présent ce
dynamisme développement local des
départements mais comme on arrive
bientôt à la fin de ce débat on va
passer autour d elle des conclusions
vous aurez à peu près chacun une minute
pour conclure un peu plus de temps est
tout de même pour la représentante du
front national sur votre conclusion
l'importance de ce scrutin aujourd'hui
tout simplement adressez vous à vos
électeurs pourquoi voter pour le front
national
le 22 mars lors du premier tour
premièrement nous nous sommes en place
sur le département et même sur le plan
national sur tous les départements
on est on est 21 représentants sur le
département du 78 donc on souhaite
décrocher des places pour le conseil
comme je vous disais pour déjà être voir
ce qui s'y passe puisqu'on n'a pas
encore de vraiment d'élus pour pouvoir
regarder tout ce qui s'y passe et et
mener nos actions et combattre certaines
choses auxquelles on n'est pas d'accord
comme on vous disait le côté surtout
intercommunalités hyper région europe là
le front national s'y opposent
complètement parce que nous nous
souhaitons garder nos communes nos
départements et l'état ce triptyque qui
est important pour le front national
ensuite tout ce qui fait partie
comme on disait de l'insécurité aussi
donc tant dans les collèges que dans les
villes par le biais de du renfort ben
justement des surveillances et puis une
gestion plus saine aussi de l'argent
public c'est à dire en contrôlant mieux
ce qui s'y passe faire des réelles
économies et avec ses économies ben pu
pouvoir aider plus les handicapés les
personnes âgées leur donner les moyens
de se déplacer dans nos villes ça c'est
le point fort du front national c'est
les handicapés et les personnes âgées
son département ça c'est notre priorité
j'avoue je vous passe la parole pour la
conclusion un peu moins d'une minute
pour moi ce sera la même chose pour les
deux autres candidats donc nous votez
pour nous pour univers citoyenne alors
d'abord démocratique avec la
transparence de ce qui se fait au
conseil général et s'appuyant sur les
décisions des citoyen et les collectifs
donc s'appuyant vraiment sur la
population écologique donc avec
l'écologie au quotidien une formation
d'aidé gens à eau
enfin il n'a comme une structuration du
territoire avec des circuits courts avec
une économie basée sur l'écologie est
une formation des gens au contest et
vous des enfants des adultes c est
solidaire donc avec tous les aspects de
la solidarité que coupet 6 ans sera pas
le dernier mot il est parti en cavale
autre conclusion simplement je dirais
que ce canton est très représentatif de
ce que l'on souhaite faire à l'avenir
dans l'ensemble du département
ils marient à la fois je dirais le
dynamisme et en particulier la vitalité
économique de saint quentin en yvelines
avec en même temps je dirais le
caractère environnemental qui est
majeure avec le parc naturel régional de
la haute vallée de chevreuse et cet
assemblage c'est une garantie à la fois
d'attractivité qualité de vie pour nos
concitoyens donc ça je crois vraiment
qu'on a la chance d'avoir pour cela un
canton très très équilibré cela dit pour
que le conseil général exerce ses
compétences il a besoin de moyens et
pour avoir des moyens il faut continuer
de soutenir le dynamisme économique
je crains effectivement que tout passe à
la région
je le regretterai profondément parce que
on a en matière de développement
économique un très beau monde en est je
crois qu'on aura besoin de ressources si
on veut que le conseil général
effectivement remplissent correctement
ses obligations malaval minutes pour
conclure moi ce que je veux dire c'est
que dans le canton ne mord pas on s'est
battu dans l'autre durant ce mandat pour
le maintien des subventions à maurepas
d'associations qui aident pour le
décrochage scolaire ce qui est très
important parce qu'elle avait perdu
leurs subventions
donc notre action a permis le maintien
de ces dossiers de subventions et c'est
très important
nous avons pu réorienter le financement
et racines travers vingt grandes
entreprises à 6 et ça c'est très
important aussi
nous avons permis aussi de la sauvegarde
et pmi dans notre canton
c'est très important aussi donc
aujourd'hui ce que je demande aux
habitants du canton ne ment pas c'est
voter pour un bilan que nous nous
jugeons très bon et je les invite à le
regarder pour poursuivre le travail
qu'on a fait parce que ils méritent
d'être poursuivis et moi et christine
merci nous sommes des élus de la société
civile qui travaillons nous ressemblons
aux habitants de ce canton et nous
appelons à voter pour nous merci madame
ismaila vague pardon et votre vie
d'homme que vous représentiez merci aux
trois autres candidats également
présents on revoit les chronomètres qui
s'affiche une dernière fois vous êtes à
peu près tous à 11 minutes 36 la
candidate du front national clair un
petit peu plus de retard cette émission
sera rediffusée jeudi 5 mars 19h samedi
7 mars 10 heures et dimanche 8 mars à 20
heures elle est bien évidemment
retrouver henry placent sur notre site
internet prochain débat la semaine
prochaine mardi 19h entre les candidats
du canton de plaisir à la présentation
catherine château à très bientôt